MaMartine, Michel David Hélène,
bobonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Tour de table sur cette
hohorrible drame. C'est tout
sisimplement horrible et la clae
popolitique le souligner de tous
leles façons possibles
auaujourd'hui.
- - Plusieurs discours à la
chchambre des communes. Il demae
àà étudier les paroles d'usage
j'j'ai noté quelques glissement,
nonotamment de cette façon que
MoMonsieur Trudeau a eue des
titickets des le gestes comme un
acacte terroriste, mais pour
l'l'instant on n'a pas de preuvs
àà cet effet. Pas que ça rende e
gegeste plus grave ou moins gra,
ilil est horrible, mais le code
crcriminel définit le terrorisme
dede manière très précise de
teterroriser les gens en ont une
cacause idéologique, et on a
auaucune preuve que cet homme
agagissait au nom d'une cause,
c'c'était plutôt la haine qui
l'l'animait. Il semble avoir de
plplus en plus de contusions au
CaCanada entre le terrorisme eta
hahaine. Les mots devraient avor
unun sens qui devrait le
rerespecter.
- - Michel David.
- - LSR que sur la communauté
mumusulmane, sacré de la craint.
- - De la terreur.
- - Dans ce sens là on peut parr
dede terrorisme au sens large. e
ququi m'a frappé aujourd'hui,
évévidemment les discours de
cicirconstance, je ne remets pas
leleur sincérité en question. Ce
n'n'est pas la première fois etn
sasait tous que ça peut se
rereproduire et qu'il est très
didifficile de prévenir ça.
cece cas-ci, l'auteur du massace
avavait aucun lien avec quelques
grgroupes qu'on connaisse. C'étt
lala même chose lors de l'attaqe
dede la grande mosquée de Québe.
OnOn peut essayer de faire
l'l'éducation, on peut essayer e
ciciviliser les réseaux sociaux,
mamais à un moment donné, il y a
dedes choses qu'on ne peut pas
évéviter, et ça je pense que tot
lele monde en est parfaitement
coconscient dans la classe
popolitique dans la société en
gégénéral.
- - Martine.
- - À Québec n'a pas fait jaser
auautant qu'on aurait pu le
pepenser. On a vu hier que
MoMonsieur Legault avait tweeté,
dédénoncé des gestes racistes
babarbares, mais aujourd'hui ila
ouvevert sa conférence de presse
auautre chose. Et rappelez-vous
quque dans quelques mois dans ls
cécérémonies, la commémoration u
ququatrième anniversaire de la
momosquée de Québec, Monsieur
LeLegault avait été fortement
ququestionné sur la question du
raracisme systémique et on sent
ququ'il est mal à l'aise avec ce
teterme la aujourd'hui et n'a ps
mimis lui-même le sujet devant.
CeCela dit, c'est sûr que c'état
susurvenu au Québec Monsieur
LeLegault aurait dit quelque
chchose, mais comme c'était en
OnOntario...
- - relève des deux solitudes ps
ququ'autre chose. C'est arrivé à
QuQuébec... et là il y a eu cete
coconférence de presse avec
MoMonsieur Trudeau ou des
jojournalistes en ont beaucoup
paparlé et ont essayé de faire n
lilien, de lui faire faire un ln
enentre ce geste haineux et la i
2121. Je vous fais entendre
MoMonsieur Trudeau réponds et va
didire ce qu'il va dire.
- - Par rapport à...
mama perspective personnelle,
leles gens savent très bien
quque je ne suis pas d'accord
avavec la loi 21. Nous allons
lalaisser les Québécois eux-mêms
amamener cette loi-là en cours,
mamais ça me surprendrait pas qe
dadans les semaines et les mois
àà venir, il y ait des réflexios
àà avoir sur le but
etet l'importance de la loi 21,
enen partie par ce que ça fait
unun an qu'on passe beaucoup
dede temps avec des masques
ququi couvrent nos visages
enen obtenant des services
dede l'État et aussi
paparce qu'il y a une réelle
ininquiétude par rapport
àà la montée d'intolérance
etet d'islamophobie.
- - Écoutez, je pense
quque les Québécois savent faire
lala différence entre un masque
popour se protéger d'un virus
pupuis d'un masque qui est porté
popour des raisons religieuses.
DoDonc, on le sait, il y a
unune majorité de Québécois qui
sosont d'accord avec la loi 21,
ququi sont d'accord pour interde
leles signes religieux pour
leles personnes qui sont en
auautorité, puis Monsieur Trude,
bibien, devrait prendre acte
dede ce que souhaite
lala majorité des Québécois.
DoDonc je résume, loi 21 est-ce
quque ça attise la haine pour
MoMonsieur Trudeau, et dit non t
apaprès dans une réflexion et dt
esest-ce que la pandémie et les
mamasques ne seraient pas de
nanature à faire réfléchir les
QuQuébécois.
- - La question qui lui est
adadressée je l'ai trouvée non
seseulement déplacer mais même
vivicieuse. L'attentat a eu en
OnOntario. La loi 21 ne s'applie
papas en Ontario. Je ne pense ps
quque ça puisse avoir une grande
ininfluence sur les esprits là-s
dadans le sens qu'on voulait
ininterdire à Monsieur Trudeau.
PoPour ce qui est du lien entrea
papandémie le masque la loi 21,
c'c'est tout à fait hors normes.
CoComme dit Monsieur Legault les
enenfants parfaitement la
didifférence. Dans les hôpitaux,
leles infirmières portent des
mamasques depuis toujours et on
n'n'a jamais pensé que ça pouvat
avavoir un lien ou une quelconqe
ininfluence sur les gens par
rarapport port du masque. Je pee
ququ'on cherche vraiment à faire
dede mauvais procès.
- - Helen Musetti à cette
coconférence de presse. Il y a u
plplusieurs tentatives de nos
cocollègues anglophones de faire
unun lien entre la haine, le
prprojet de loi 21.
- - Ces trois questions de trois
jojournalistes différents qui ot
fafait cette adéquation entre
LoLondon et loi 21. Moi je troue
ququand même intéressant que
MoMonsieur Trudeau a dit oui et
nonon à la fois. Répond d'abord
nonon à la question ensuite dans
l'l'extrait que vous avez fait
jojouer en lampe dans ce qu'il t
leles gens auront des réflexions
papar rapport à la loi 21
coconsidérant la montée des de
l'l'intolérance et de
l'l'islamophobie. Ne pas faire n
lilien entre les deux, je ne sas
papas ce que c'est. Par ailleurs
soson commentaire sur le masque
dédémontre qu'il comprend mal à
didimension de ce débat-là. Lui
ququand il dit ça fait un an qun
a a des services de l'État toutn
ététant masqués ce n'est pas un
prproblème, semble dire que la i
2121 ce n'est qu'une question de
sésécurité des et
d'd'identification. La loi 21 ce
n'n'est pas que sur le voile
inintégral, ce sont tous les
sysymboles religieux, et ce quia
amamené le gouvernement ce n'est
papas seulement d'identifier les
cicitoyens, de pouvoir s'assurer
ququ'on a bel et bien à faire àa
mmême personne mais c'est aussi
dadans le symbole, le signal qun
enenvoie quand la laïcité de
l'l'État.
- - Martine je vous donne la
paparole, je vous montre un twet
dede collègues du globe,
chchroniqueuse.
AuAu Canada anglais, on continuà
fafaire le lien en disant que la
loloi 21 cible les musulmans, cr
cece n'est que les musulmans qui
poportent le voile.
- - Le lien est quand même boitx
enentretien qui est arrivé à
LoLondon et un couvre visage. Et
sisi on a été très surpris de la
dédéclaration de Monsieur Legaut
etet Monsieur Legault a fait un
chchoix réfléchi. Il a donné une
réréponse très tempérée parce qe
c'c'est fini les chicanes inutis
n'n'a trouvé c'était boiteuse qe
MoMonsieur Trudeau a dit, etet e
dedemander....
- - ça montre que ce débat... le
grgros du débat est passé au
QuQuébec. N'est pas fini ça
cocontinue en cours mais il y ea
bebeaucoup qui n'accepte pas que
MoMonsieur Trudeau se soit pas
lelevé contre cette loi la au
QuQuébec.
- - Absolument, et dès le départ
auau Canada anglais on on s'est
élélevé contre la loi 21. London
leleur donne un nouveau souffleà
ceces attaques la j'ajouterai
pepeut-être la loi 96 la sommatn
dede nation québécoise, ça aussi
çaça contribue à raviver
l'l'allergie qui est toujours là
cocontre toute affirmation de la
didifférence québécoise et on mt
totous dans la même tas. La
réréaction de la chroniqueuse ne
meme surprend pas.
- - Mais Hélène ne vous surprend
papas qu'elle ait choisi de faie
çaça, il est choisi aujourd'huià
momoins de 24 heures d'un drame
épépouvantable.
- - En fait ça va plus loin ence
quque la loi 21. C'est Élisabeth
mimire à la chambre des communes
ququi disait on a tous une parte
reresponsabilité qui devrait
dédénoncer tout politicien qui
vovoudrait nous diviser sur la
ququestion du hijab. Plus
ququestionner le port du hijab r
çaça peut mener à la haine et un
mamassacre comme à London. Mme y
sesemblait nous dire que toutes
ceces questions-là ne sont plus
lélégitimes par ce qu'elle
rerevienne à remettre en questin
d'd'une certaine pratique
mumusulmane et donc d'endosser a
hahaine envers eux. D'aller très
loloin et je sens que c'est une
tetendance assez lourde du côtéu
CaCanada anglais.
- - Conclusion sur un autre sujt
avavant de se quitter. Le
papasseport vaccinal. Il semble
ququand on fait la somme, en
jujuillet, les doubles vaccinés
popourront revenir plus en paixu
papays une fois qu'ils auront
vovoyagée et pourront même aller
auaux États-Unis. Le fameux
papasseport vaccinal va exister.
- - Ici on parle de preuve
vavaccinale, ils sont peu
alallergiques au mot passeport
vavaccinal. Ce que dit Monsieur
DuDubé, c'est que c'est vraiment
popour les voyageurs. On s'est
bibien gardé de cibler des
rerestaurants ou des salles de
spspectacles, mais on sent qu'il
vava y avoir autre chose à veni.
C'C'est sûr que les doubles
vavaccinés vont avoir certains
prprivilèges. On s'en va vers ds
lalaissez-passer.
- - Pour ce qui est des voyages,
jeje pense qu'il était entendu s
mamal que ce serait exigé, et ps
jujuste au Canada, tous les
trtransporteurs au monde vont
avavoir les mêmes exigences quat
auau voyage. Pour le reste, je
seserais très surpris que le
gogouvernement impose la preuve
vavaccinale, pour les services
esessentiels, santé éducation et
mmême pour les restaurants,
ththéâtres. Je pense qu'il faut
plplutôt dire qui ne sera pas
ininterdit aux restaurateurs mas
cece ne sera pas le gouvernement
ququi va l'exiger.
- - Même ça je ne suis pas
cecertaine. Voyages oublient, ma